[Aplausos]
[Música]
Bienvenidos a diario del mundial el
programa de France 24 donde actualizamos
y analizamos el día a día de la Copa
Mundial de la FIFA Qatar 2022 a
continuación nuestros titulares
Argentina avanza con suspenso la
selección de Lionel escalón y derrotó a
Australia y avanzó a los cuartos de
final de la presente edición de la copa
del mundo en dicha instancia los espera
Países Bajos vuelo que tiene una carga
histórico deportiva importante tenemos
detalles desde Qatar
la naranja está de regreso tras que dar
en el tercer puesto en la copa del mundo
de 2014 y estar ausente en 2018
dirigió El Avance de la selección de
Países Bajos a los cuartos de final del
mundial de Qatar 2022 Memphis abrió la
cuenta para los europeos en el partido
frente a Estados Unidos Tenemos reporte
de este Qatar
el segundo día de los octavos de final
tendrá Además del Duelo entre Inglaterra
y senegal el choque entre Francia y
Polonia será la primera vez que kilian
mbappé y Robert lewandowski se vean
frente a frente vistiendo los colores de
sus elecciones nacionales
para analizar el acontecer de cada
jornada Contamos con la presencia de
Octavio sazo periodista de la emisora
Blu radio en Colombia bienvenido Octavio
Hola Luis Buenas tardes Un gusto como
siempre Muchísimas gracias También
aprovecho para darle la bienvenida a
nuestra empleada especial en
Qatar Natalia Ruiz giraldo que nos trae
todos los detalles de primera mano de lo
que ocurre en ese país Saludos Natalia
Saludos para todos ustedes nuestro
compañero Juan pupiales también desde
qatarse estará incorporando más adelante
iniciamos Argentina dos veces campeona
del mundo ha sido recurrente En los
cuartos de final desde el torneo
celebrado en Alemania 2006 esto luego de
haberse quedado en la primera fase
durante la Copa del Mundo de Corea y
Japón en el año 2002 sin embargo luego
de tres clasificaciones consecutivas
entre 2006 y 2014 con el subcampeonato
en este último torneo la racha se rompió
en 2018 cuando cayó frente a Francia en
los octavos de final pero en Qatar todo
ha sido distinto y tras comenzar con una
derrota frente a Arabia Saudita a los
dirigidos por Lionel scaloni han logrado
enmendar la carga y ya están en cuartos
de final nuevamente esto al derrotar a
Australia con marcador de dos goles por
uno gracias a los tantos tele Lionel
Messi y Julián Álvarez Así aprovechamos
para conversar con Natalia Ruiz Natalia
sabemos en en primer lugar que un
ambiente de euforia sabemos que estuvo
tomando té durante todo este partido
pero que otros detalles nos puedes
ofrecer acerca de este compromiso
Bueno pues fue digamos sobre todo un
gran partido en las tribunas estas
45.000 personas que estaban en este
estadio y un puñadito nada más de
australianos con un par de canguros
inflables tratando hacer de allí como
una una mancha en medio de toda esa
marea albiceleste que no dejó de cantar
que no dejó de alentar que no dejó de de
saltar todavía hay algunos que están
pasando incluso por aquí cerca cantando
y sobre todo cuando levantaban los
brazos en el momento en que ya Messi
marcaba ese primer gol en el minuto 35
Como el todo el estadio gritaba Messi
Messi Messi Messi levantaban los brazos
en signo de de Alabanza a su número diez
que fue el hombre de este partido que
estuvo magnífico a lo largo de todo este
encuentro que estuvo muy difícil y que
por poco pues se le sale de las manos a
Argentina sobre todo ya a la final
después de que finalmente pues Australia
lograra descontar en el minuto 77
gracias a goodwin y un disparo que
finalmente terminando sobre el brazo de
Enzo Fernández y termina metiéndose en
portería propia
interesante este análisis sobre todo
porque presionó en este compromiso la
selección de Australia pero precisamente
Octavio quisiera evaluar a esta
selección que se coló por la vía de
repechaje a Qatar luego a disputar sus
partidos de ronda eliminatoria en la
parte asiática o la conferencia asiática
Precisamente en Qatar conoce muy bien
los estadios conoce muy bien el clima
pero luego de una vamos a decir
intermitente primera fase complicó un
poco al combinado de Leonel scalonia a
lo largo de este partido sí Luis sobre
todo en el en el segundo tiempo y yo
creo que tiene que ver en principio con
el desgaste físico de Argentina y con la
potencia física valga la redundancia del
seleccionado australiano hay que
recordar que Argentina llegó con muy
poco descanso este partido que
evidentemente lo sufrió se agotó en el
segundo tiempo sobre todo sobre el final
cuando Argentina ya las piernas no le
daban para seguir manejando el ritmo que
habían impuesto en ese segundo tiempo y
Australia que físicamente era superior
terminó obligándolo a retroceder además
dejó espacios el equipo australiano que
Argentina no aprovechó para marcar la
diferencia y por eso Australia termina
complicando pero es un equipo que tiene
virtudes y que tiene esa virtud física
de la que hablamos que es un equipo
ordenado que tiene disciplina que Que
bueno que se parece a lo que quiere
conseguir su entrenador pero que le
falta jerarquía como para poder dominar
a un rival que tiene un jugador como
como Lionel Messi se impusieron En
algunos momentos del partido por esa por
esa misma potencia por la capacidad que
tienen como para influir sobre equipos
que tengan la pelota que manejen el El
dominio del juego y y aprovecharon
también esa facilidad o entre comillas
ese esa posibilidad que tuvieron con el
gol que entró de rebote para poder
asustar un poco a los argentinos pero
más allá de todo eso Australia se va
luego de me parece a mí hacer una buena
copa para
objetivos que tenía el equipo
australiano que además Luis hay que
decir que llegó a este mundial por por
el repechaje y dejando fuera la
selección peruana Entonces al final
cumple me parece el objetivo que era
pelear mano a mano con Argentina y y
bueno despedirse del mundial en una
segunda ronda en la que nadie contaba
con ellos interesante este dato sobre
todo para los peruanos Pues que quedaron
eliminados ante un equipo que ya está
entre los 16 mejores de este torneo
mencionabas Octavio el tema de los días
de descanso hay que recordar que Qatar
para poder jugar esta copa del mundo
redujo la cantidad de días de
competencia a 29 de los 32 que nos
venían acostumbrando desde Brasil 2014 y
que coincidió también en Rusia 2018 pero
Natalia qué decir del juego de Lionel
Messi nos comentabas que los fanáticos
estuvieron eufóricos con su accionar a
lo largo del partido frente a Australia
se vio por momentos muy participa pero
fue señalado tras la derrota de
Argentina frente a Arabia Saudita esos
pasajes de ese compromiso frente a
Arabia Saudita Ya quedaron en el pasado
Pues todo diría que que sí justamente
después de la prestación de de él el día
de hoy y a pesar de haber fallado ese
penalti en el partido pasado ante
Polonia pero hoy lo que vimos fue el
gran mes y el gran Messi que celebraba
hoy su partido número 1000 de su carrera
y lo celebró digamos con bombos y
platillos sacando de nuevo esos Más allá
de los visos fue por muchos instantes
ese Leonel Messi que teníamos la
costumbre de ver en el Barcelona sobre
todo que es donde más brillo un poco
menos con la albiceleste y tuvimos
momentos increíbles donde de alguna
manera pues se cortaba casi que la
respiración de todos estos almas en este
estadio viendo lo que él lo podía hacer
y de cómo Pues él es el hombre que logró
hacer la diferencia a lo largo de todo
este partido se le vio de hecho además
correr más de lo que generalmente estaba
haciendo porque últimamente pues Lionel
Messi camina mucho sobre la cancha y
finalmente hoy le vimos atacando le
vimos defendiendo se le vio mucho más
digamos como liberado un poco así que
esta vez pues iba ya muy finito con con
con la idea de lo que necesitaba y bueno
al final de cuentas no funcionó esa
dupla al final con con lautaro Martínez
que entró por Julián Álvarez lautaro
Martínez que falló al menos unas dos
ocasiones que eran prácticamente claras
de Gol pero fue Sí una gran Leonel Messi
y lo único preocupante en realidad o lo
preocupante En todo caso diría yo es que
Argentina vuelve a depender muchísimo de
su número diez para poder salir adelante
varios de la redacción lamentaron estas
fallas de lautaro Martínez en ese
compromiso pero así entonces Argentina
va a rivalizar contra Países Bajos un
duelo que tiene mucha historia en copas
del mundo porque entre otros partidos
está la final del torneo en 1978 que fue
realizado en Argentina y ganado por
Argentina precisamente países bajo en
otro duelo de la jornada y que abrió
estos octavos de final superó tres goles
por la selección de Estados Unidos
Memphis abrió la cuenta para los
naranjas a los 10 minutos amplió la
misma en el agregado de la primera
partida puso el tres por uno en el
minuto 81 con ello le bajo revoluciones
a un Estados Unidos que había descontado
minutos antes por intermedio de wright a
los 76 pero para conocer más detalles de
este encuentro veamos el siguiente
trabajo de nuestro enviado especial en
Qatar Juan pupiales
la naranja Esta vez fue más efectiva que
mecánica victoria de tres a uno para los
Países Bajos contra Estados Unidos para
volver a los cuartos de final de un
mundial como lo hicieran ya en Brasil
2014 un encuentro que tuvo un libreto
oportunidad al minuto 2 para Estados
Unidos Christian pulisis que fue salvada
por el portero North 8 minutos más tarde
ataque de los neerlandeses centro de
damperes y gol de Memphis de pie el
primero en esta copada mundo para él al
final del Descanso de nuevo oportunidad
para el combinado de las barras y las
estrellas esta vez en los pies de
sergiño Desde que la desperdició y en la
jugada prácticamente siguiente centro de
nuevo de dan Fresh y estaba su compañero
Por la izquierda Blend y va a poner el 2
a 0 de la tranquilidad para los segundos
45 minutos llegó la reacción desde el
banquillo del combinado de las barras y
las estrellas con la entrada de
jugadores como the Andrew
Grey de su último autor del gol del
descuento en esos segundos 45 minutos
pero de nuevo y va a repetirse el guión
reacción rápida de los neerlandeses esta
vez con un gol de danzas que sin duda
alguna fue el hombre del partido con
esas dos asistencias y un tanto para los
neerlandeses es volverse a meter entre
las 8 mejores selecciones del mundo lo
reitero su seleccionador Luis bangal
estamos aquí para ganar el Mundial
Estados Unidos uno de los equipos más
jóvenes de esta copa que se va después
de haber mostrado un buen nivel le
llaman Soccer pero juega muy bien al
fútbol
interesante ese dato sobre Estados
Unidos Juan precisamente país que
albergará junto a Canadá y México la
próxima edición de la copa del mundo
pero Octavio se habla mucho de esta
selección de países bajo que no había
demostrado su mejor fútbol y que por
momentos vio comprometida su
clasificación a esta fase de octavos de
final pero lo ha dicho bangal la
experiencia que tiene sobre este tipo de
partido Parece que fue determinante a la
hora de sacar un resultado frente a
Estados Unidos claramente Luis los
jugadores de Países Bajos normalmente
están en este tipo de competencias Más
allá de la Copa del Mundo definen
partidos de liga de campeones de Europa
juega en la Champions ya más alto nivel
y evidentemente cuando tiene jugadores
como grillo anday como Memphis depay
como Blind como el propio Don fris que
fue el que terminó marcando el 3 a 1
puedes hacer una diferencia en cuanto a
que haya esos jugadores no les tiembla
el pulso a la hora de ir mano a mano
definir en este tipo de situaciones los
Estados Unidos por su parte es un equipo
que me parece que tiene mucho más
talento que Países Bajos pero que
evidentemente la mayoría de ellos no
tenía la experiencia como para poder
combatir el nervio también y entender
Cómo ganar un partido en estas en estas
instancias de todas maneras el resultado
me pareció en algún momento muy largo
para lo que fue el partido es cierto que
Países Bajos fue superior a los Estados
Unidos en la mayor parte del juego pero
mereció otra suerte de los Estados
Unidos que termina Incluso acercándose
en el marcador luego el tres a uno lo
estira y marca la diferencia Países
Bajos va a ser un rival muy duro para el
seleccionador argentino sobre todo por
esa rivalidad que contabas al inicio
porque también han jugado en la Copa del
98 con aquel gol de berkham que lo saca
del mundial porque se vieron las caras
en Brasil 2014 porque hay mucha
rivalidad entre ellos dos Me parece que
llega un poco mejor Argentina Porque
además va a tener seis días de descanso
el equipo argentino para recuperarse
pero Países Bajos es un equipo de temer
y tiene jugadores de de mucha jerarquía
como para poder combatir ya cuando van a
quedar ocho mejores equipos del mundial
ya vamos a tener tiempo para analizar lo
que va a ser esta confrontación directa
entre Argentina y Países Bajos pero la
selección de Estados Unidos si bien
cumplió con lo esperado no dejó una mala
actuación como bien lo decías Octavio y
texto se puede tomar de base a la Copa
del año 2026 por lo menos así ya lo está
viendo la asociación de fútbol de
Estados Unidos que a través de un
mensaje en la red social Twitter
agradeció la actuación y el respaldo de
los fanáticos a lo largo de todo este
viaje que comenzó con las exigentes
eliminatorias de Concacaf también la
actuación del combinado estadounidense
fue generada por reacciones del
presidente de esa nación Joe biden quien
dijo que se sintió orgulloso Y destacó
el futuro brillante de Cara a 2026
cuando serán sede
pero luego de los dos primeros partidos
de octavos de final que estuvieron
emocionantes y nos brindaron buen fútbol
la acción continuará este domingo con
otros dos partidos por lo menos
se muestra en el papel que van a ser muy
cerrados a primera hora saltarán al
terreno las elecciones de Francia y
Polonia Francia una candidata a pelear
por un puesto en la final y una Polonia
que si bien Hace cuatro años se esperaba
mucho más de ella Este año sorprendió al
colarse a octavos de final con los
justos empate con México Victoria sobre
Arabia Saudita y una derrota frente a
Argentina Natalia le quisiera consultar
Le tocará a usted estar en este partido
mañana y por otro lado aprovechando la
cercanía que tuvo con la selección
francesa siente que este fue uno de los
partidos que pudo estar pensando de
champs antes de la copa del mundo para
estos octavos de final y qué
expectativas podemos tener sobre el
mismo en Qatar
Bueno pues sí como estás bien lo decía
puede ser un partido bastante difícil
para el de blues y de solo tenía en
mente o no difícil saberlo pero sí
sabemos que pues ellos están muy al
tanto de que Polonia ha estado
entrenándose y han estado también
ensayando los tiros desde lo punto penal
más ahí andas Pues de que cuentan con Ah
en el arco el que ha atajado el 90% de
pelotas en este a lo largo de todo este
mundial ha atajado dos penales uno de
ellos a Leonel Messi en el último
partido ya de octavos Así que los
franceses saben muy bien que van a tener
una muralla que atravesar a lo largo de
esos 90 minutos y Francia pues son que
va a sacar otra vez su 11 estelar
después de esa ese equipo suplente que
sacó ante túnez que nos dejó un poco
anonadados a todos porque se veía que
todavía pues son jugadores muy jóvenes
que no tienen la experiencia no tienen
el nivel y finalmente cuando entran ya
los jugadores con más pues finalmente el
partido cambió y pues le dio muchas más
opciones de de ofensivas a Francia Así
que se tienen Sí ya pensado que va a
sacar ese once que estará Teo Hernández
que venía con una molestia en uno de de
sus tobillos Estará presente estará
Conde estará por supuesto vagan y upa
Mecano Y pues obviamente saldrá ahí al
frente con todo ese Arsenal poderoso con
dembélez mbappé y llegó Pero sí es un
partido bastante difícil no hay que
olvidar que enfrente pues tienen a
lewandowski a pesar de que Polonia Pues
a lo largo de este mundial tan solo ha
tenido cinco tiros a portería hay que
ver entonces cómo se planteará Polonia
frente a este Arsenal ya que es una
selección polaca que está en sus
primeros octavos de final desde
1986 pero el fútbol ha cambiado mucho y
más en Europa y no sabremos qué
planteamiento podría ofrecer Polonia en
estos partidos de eliminación directa
pero dada la capacidad ofensiva de
Francia está en Polonia Octavio detener
la pelota cuidarla y aprovechar al
máximo las ocasiones que se le genere va
a ser muy difícil Luis yo creo Fíjate lo
que decía Natalia Natalia hablaba de la
sorpresa que habíamos tenido todos con
la cantidad de suplentes de Francia
seguramente Francia no va a sufrir como
Argentina el desgaste porque Francia
tuvo la posibilidad de descansar a sus
jugadores no como Argentina que hoy lo
que hoy lo sufrió tanto vamos a ver una
Francia diferente yo creo que Polonia le
va a costar mucho Polonia ha mostrado
muy poco en esta copa del mundo y yo no
creo que sea frente a Polonia que se
vaya a destapar es decir la realidad de
Polonia es que es un equipo que que
compite que tiene una defensa o que
tiene la defensa lo mejor que tiene y
vaya que decir esto pensando en
lewandowski y elnski por ejemplo es Es
complicado pero de la mitad hacia
adelante Polonia genera muy poco no es
casualidad el dato que daba Natalia de
que sólo cinco disparos al arco y yo
creo que frente al actual campeona del
mundo de un equipo con esa potencia no
creo que sea el partido para que Polonia
pueda destaparse
de todas maneras le va a poner no se le
va a poner tan fácil a Francia pero yo
creo que Polonia llega hasta acá que
Polonia no está en las condiciones para
ir a pelear mano a mano con esta Francia
de de diviertens que seguramente seguirá
en camino de aquí en adelante el otro
partido que completa La Jornada de
mañana será Inglaterra frente a senegal
aprovecho Octavio para darte las gracias
por todo este análisis a Natalia desde
Qatar también a Juan pupiales nuestros
enviados especiales en territorio catarí
y a ustedes por estar con nosotros de
esta manera le ponemos punto final a
diario del mundial por el día de hoy
continúen con más de la programación de
France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]